هل سيكون الذكاء الاصطناعي اذكى من البشر
هذا هو السؤال الان وهل سيتحول لسلاح قاتل
كما شاهدنا في افلام الخيال العلمي
تساؤلات مطروحه خاصه بعدما اعلن قبل ايام
مات كليفورد مستشار رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني لشؤون الذكاء والتكنولوجيا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يصبح قويا بما
يكفي لقتل العديد من البشر في غضون عامين
فقط التحذير هذا كان ايضا دعوه لوضع نظم
وتشريعات لمنتجي ومطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي
على نطاق عالمي كي لا تخرج الامور يوما
معا السيطره لاحقا جدد سام التمان المدير
التنفيذي لشركه اوبن اي ال مخاوفه وقال ان
التوتر جعله يصاب بالارق بعد اطلاق روبوت
الذره
اضاف التمان ان اطلاق هذا الروبوت للدردشه
ليس شيئا سيئا الا ان المخاوف تتمثل في ان
يستغل احد هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي وحذر من
تسببه في انقراض البشريه لكن وعلى الرغم
من توالي التحذيرات الى ان خبراء تقنيه
توقعوا بان لا يخرج الذكاء الاصطناعي عن
سيطره الانسان على الاقل في المدى القصير
المنظور ومع ذلك قال خبراء ان الخطر
الاكبر في الذكاء الاصطناعي ليس خروجه عن
السيطره بل في استخدامه بشكل سيء من جانب
الدول او حتى الشركات المتطوره او ان يكون
الذكاء الاصطناعي ساحه لسباق تسلح من نوع
جديد في العالم لكن في حال ما اذا كان او
اصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي اذكى او اقوى من
المبرمجين فكيف ستتعامل الحكومات مثلا مع
اي حوادث مستقبليه
عقيد مفهوم
الذكاء نيات العامله به ينعكس على تحديد
مسؤوليه المبرمج عن اخطاء هذه التقنيه على
سبيل المثال في حاله حدوث وفاه ما
المسؤوليه الجنائيه المترتبه على هذه
الاخطاء
بسبب غياب التشريعات حتى اللحظه يرى
مختصون اهميه وضع قوانين لدراسه التطور
السريع لهذه التقنيه كما خرجت دعوات
الافتراض مشاكل واضرار مستقبليه قد تنجم
عن الذكاء الاصطناعي والاته لوضع المجتمع
في صوره العقوبات ومنع وقوع اي تخبط عند
وقوع اي ضرر كبيرا كان ام صغيرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات